You're still here.
All right, cool.
Well, if you're wondering
what to do next,
there's a few things I'd
recommend checking out.
All the links are in
the instructor notes below.
If you haven't already, check out
the offline web application course.
It's not just about offline, but
dives deeper into service workers,
the mechanics of caching and index db.
Even though we use promises in this
course, we didn't cover them at all.
So if you've never seen them before, or
if you're still trying to wrap your head
around them, check out
the JavaScript Promises course.
We're working on a course for
push notifications right now.
But in the meantime,
we've got a code lab that you can use
to add push notifications
to your weather app.
There's also the web tooling and
animation course which will
help you level up your skills.
I learned a few good things
by taking that course.
I'm sure I'm missing something.
So take a look at the instructor
notes for any updates or
anything new and in a word of
one of my heroes, it's over.
Go home, go.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Why are you still here?
Thanks for sticking with me.
Kind of quiet and lonely in here.
They wouldn't let me have
the little clapper thing.
I wanted that, it was fun.
There was a picture on the back
that was always fun to look at.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> All right.
[LAUGH] I think we can cut now.